This has been my latest pregnancy craving.
So it's pistachio ice cream.
Okay, then I made some homemade caramel sauce today,
so I'm gonna put some of that on.
Actually never had this.
It just sounded good in my mind.
I wanted pistachio ice cream with caramel sauce on top.
And my husband made some cookie dough,
so I just need cookie dough on top of this.
This better be good.
I've been thinking about this for days.
This is what we're working with.
Okay, let's try it.
Uh huh.
That's exactly what it tasted like in my mind.
Wow. Uh huh. Pistachio ice cream,
caramel syrup, rock. Cookie dough.
This is gonna be on my late night snack rotations.
Pistachio ice cream is an underrated ice cream flavor.
We stand by that.